with Windsor waiting the president
dropping in for tea with the King
a formal welcome with the warmth of
friendship
it is a diplomatic display
the Monarch's soft power on full show
as a new king reaffirms an old Alliance
thank you
yeah thank you very much
the president couldn't make the
coronation but he wanted to be seen here
I'm eating inside the castle on the
climate crisis a subject close to both
heads of state King Charles has been
involved in this for 60 years and he was
way ahead of the curve on a lot of this
and President Biden likewise was way
ahead in the U.S Senate
it was a flying visit but an important
moment for anglo-american relations an
upbeat spokesperson for the king
described the meeting as both cordial
and successful
earlier at Downing Street another
display of unity
President Biden met the Prime Minister
Rishi sunak
they may have differences but over tea
political pleasantries exchanged but
it's a great pleasure to have you here
it's good to be back you know we've
owned a meeting once a month the
president assuring relations remain Rock
Solid
and then to Air Force One for President
Biden the British trip over next stop
NATO Laura bundock Sky News Windsor